there's only like a few people I think
in the world that can keep up with us
and I think are funny and I think
Martellus Bennett is one of those guys
well thank you I think that's a
compliment
yeah it was a weird compliment your
brother too he could be with us too oh
yeah that would've been good yeah you're
two of our favorites you know the grape
doesn't fall far from the vine that's
what they say yeah yeah I like since
it's a quarterback I get to sit next to
him Joe right also I think this is the
Eagles fans now well I don't know he's
officially an eagle I am I Eagles fan
I hear you jump on the bandwagon I do
not know I'm a Michael Bennett fan yes
for he plays for the Eagles so I'm
rooting for him to do well so I'm
rooting for them to do well yes okay
take flight eCos flies the worst song
ever written to the national anthem
right Elias at the end though no I don't
like any of it
I mean if I played for them I would love
it perfect but you're gonna say it's
like say I like country music
I would love country music but I don't
like country music what was it like
Sunday being a fan that's like your
first I didn't watch much football
Sunday what did i do on Sunday Sunday
oh I was at Harvard head so that's where
you get the sweatshirt just you know
this is like when you go to New York you
get a heart New York shirt no nobody
does now I lived in Boston and never got
a Harvard shirt but you never went to
Harvard I did Taylor cross over a
program know that I was not for sure but
I did go over there yes the I'm part of
a MBA program over there so I felt like
it was official even I'm not a harvest
do it gotcha I realized I would have did
very well in those classes besides the
point that you have to raise your hand
to X question is I just don't get that
[ __ ] oh I'm leaving that I'm too old for
that [ __ ] did you ever get build a left
cuz you're funny dude or I may build s
was there one that comes to mind now he
laughed so often around me the the key
was to get him this the key was to get
him to smirk
so if you give him a smirk like he's
about to laugh when he doesn't laugh do
you know that he was laughing in his
heart I know the smirk you're talking
about he's gonna give you it's like I
respect like yeah that's just funny
buddy gonna laughing like that's a good
one yeah staying back to the details
here yeah our first Sunday was not the
same that's why he's a lot cooler than
me
I mean my first Sunday without football
I was a wreck I was crying
really I was the like the exact opposite
I was watching every game and like I
can't believe this guy's pulling and I'm
not so but I was wondering this though
yeah is it different
we retired when you want to retire and
when the league pushes you I think so
and they push me out see I retired when
I wanted right Oh again I'm so I'm happy
with what I did you know a lot of guys I
think they're I want to say bitter nicer
but they're bitter about someone else
being in if like they still could do it
again so go play then you go try out for
the the Canada team that never we - not
happening no NFL or nothing yeah so yeah
I get that but for me it's just been
I've been the happiest ever been as it
well I've been happy before brother
happier like I'm happy happy like human
happy like a happy human being like hey
I get to do whatever I want to do get
smoke weed not worry about you test it
okay
cake for breakfast you know all kinds of
[ __ ] and it's just like I just live I
get to draw all day do it and I'm on my
own time
yeah and I own my day like I could go
meet my wife for margaritas in the
middle of the day which is so awesome
because in football for eight months you
can never go to lunch with another wife
right so you eat cake for breakfast
every once in a while just to remind
myself that I'm in charge in my life
tell the universe yeah well one other
thing about New England I find
fascinating cuz you're one of the
freakiest tight ends I've ever seen and
been around just because your size speed
blocking combo but you were there with
another freak of nature like was that
weird for you at first to be like damn
this guy's as big as me he moves like me
so it's interesting because I first met
Rob I was doing MMA in and LA and he was
in the same gym we were working on his
site he came he's like it's all that
sweat I was like yeah [ __ ] I get
it in yeah and he's like he's like oh me
too you know that's kind of like how we
bond right there you know like we work
hard and then
oh that's amazing
I've never made anyone sweats more to me
I was like hey Rob like I'm a grunt he's
like I like that I like that it didn't
like a day later I got traded to the
Patriots even though we were similar
world so much different yeah you don't
sound so like you know and that's the
one thing I thought Josh did very well
like I was like Josh I like to get the
ball in my hand early so I could turn it
around and do what I do with the ball
Gronk likes the deeper route so we
parent we matched very well so there was
Gronk cross and I was Marty routes and
my coach Dave ball was very good because
he didn't try to treat us the same a
coach is the same so there was some like
he'll be like hey Marty look at this
gate state which I appreciate when
coaches bring you other people's tape
he's like I just wanna watch you watch
these 20 cut ups and see if there's any
routes cuz I think some of those are
ones want to add to your game right
anytime a coach comes to you and like we
want to add something to your game
you've like I'm down there for it and
there's not a lot of coaches that do
that people don't realize that people
think that all coaches are created equal
and they're not they're not known at all
no they're not I mean Gronk liked it too
because we balance each other very out
and I'm very well now I think we liked
each other because we both could block
yeah cuz nothing's worse than being on a
doily tight end of the block and one
guy's just running all the rouse and you
could catch the ball tunas just like
yeah I'll bash my head against Julius
Pampers over here you go get fantasy
points I hate that [ __ ] I don't like if
you can't don't [ __ ] put them in they
can you know everything I'm okay with
guys eating but at the same time like
you gotta be doing everything at the
position don't come in and I him run a
deep route so I can fake the pass
protected you were talking earlier about
retiring when you want and be enforced
town I feel like I'm looking at DES and
I'm seeing the tweets and I can see the
frustration how is happening with DES
right now I think there's this
perception right these perceptions these
teams could build perceptions about
players right and if you take a meeting
and you don't kill that perception in a
meeting they start to believe what I can
learn reality yeah it becomes your
reality so I think what day is this
thing I think that you know trying to
control the situation but at the same
time the best thing you could do to
control the situation is just to
physically you can still play there's
like people saw an Eric Decker and yes
like you know there's receivers getting
signed all the time now the talents
there same thing over like your era
greed like there's safeties getting
something they can't play better
agrees just like what you went past upon
his God and game though how do you see
des n didn't like endgame here because I
don't want him to go too long without
playing here too cuz like I like des - I
don't think he's a superstar anymore but
I want to see him on the field and he
deserves to be on the field and to play
with a quarterback I think the
personality of the quarterback is gonna
make des a better player right so
playing with a Tom Brady or playing with
a Philip Rivers who has that fire yes
and kamesh des is firing he believes in
that fire
there's gonna be a better situation for
him because he's my heart they both have
that mutual respect for one another
right as far as competitors all these
coaches talk about they want guys who
love football like let's get some
football guys in here and they but when
you have a guy who loved football so
much mmm
then they label him as a guy that's like
a diva but he just wants to win he wants
to play and he loves playing football so
if you could get those three things out
of most guys cuz most guys don't really
love it the way they say they love it
they just say that [ __ ] until they get
the check because most of these people
aren't who they really say they are just
a facade yes and Fugazi
yeah just they just played a game very
well that wasn't into playing a game I
was into playing a game of football but
you got to win at the game of life as
well so I [ __ ] whatever this uh this
feel good for you what this I mean this
there's three somewhere happens you have
fun yeah yeah I like talking to you guys
you guys are some my favorite you're our
homie man just so you know like we've
talked about you and your brother like
non-stop over the last few years yeah I
appreciate your pink nails
I appreciate what you can see that I got
so what happened was this is the last
thing I'll tell the people of the show
so my I got ready to do TV last week and
my daughter thought my nails need be
done so she painted them pink and I was
like cool as a good father that's a
conscious [ __ ] you do you do tea parties
and you do you paint nails with each
other you leave your nails pink because
that's what daddies and daughters do you
know so yeah but when she painted it she
used to have the cheek polish but now
that she's older it's not the kind of
pills off and no one in the house seems
to have fingernail polish remover
because everyone goes to the nail salon
to get their nails done
so I'm trying to chip it off away for
almost like two weeks and I'm just so
busy that I never think about it and I
actually started liking a little bit I
kind of
it's not perfect and it's messed up it's
like I'm gonna says like I'm sorry I'm
an artist yeah so it's just she just
added to my branding Martellus we
appreciate you man again check out
Martellus just show mostly football
yahoo and complex and my new podcast
called revenge of the jocks oh you're
the jock i want to have a little more
flavor to you you're like you know like
you'll have as much cacao yeah we got
back